So, we
are the Public Health Group.
And I'm Milind I'm gonna be
presenting on behalf of our
group.
And so, we have some problems
that we thought are ready for
immediate collaboration.
I'm gonna ask my teammates
to jump in if I misrepresent
anything.
And so
immediate collaboration and
then interesting
long term problems.
So, immediate collaboration is
assignment and scheduling of
health-worker visits with
dynamically generated data.
So as I understand it,
we have health workers and
they have to plan routes.
So, each person is assigned
maybe a thousand people have to
visit on a large geography.
They have to ideally visit
each and every home but
that may not work, so
you may do a risk based routing.
So people who have
a higher risk,
you want to make sure
that they do get visited.
And so this problem becomes one
of a traveling salesman problem,
but interesting because there's
some places have a higher value
to be visited.
And then the problem
can be made more and
more complicated because we may
want to optimize which health
worker takes on which route.
The roots may not be
known in advance so
they may be learning of
the routes as we go on, we might
want to build on existing
relationships and so forth.
So we created a four part
evaluation of each problem that
we discussed, social relevance,
how interesting is it
from an AI perspective,
collaboration opportunity,
and availability of data.
And this problem seemed to score
high in terms of all of these
dimensions, and so this we
consider as our top priority.
A second problem was risk based
targeting of patients for
tele advising and monitoring.
You can see that there is some
overlap here in the risk based
approach.
So basic idea is that,
this is a problem where
we have to call patients.
Unfortunately if you
call all the patients all
the time it's very
costly to the patients.
And so can we target which
patients are more risk prone and
therefore those are the ones you
would target a little bit more.
And so this is apparently
something where
the GatesFoundation has data,
and something where
we may have some contacts
in order to get that data.
The first problem
that I mentioned,
this assignment problem it seems
like there's already years of
data available, and so
that's why this seemed to
be the more interesting problem
to focus on right away.
So these two are our problems
for immediate collaboration and
then longer term possibly
more challenging problems was
slum health monitoring.
Here we are trying to geolocate
diseases within a slum,
predict some areas are prone to
certain diseases, and therefore,
recommend actions to start
medicine, awareness camps,
screen for
certain diseases in those areas.
This is also a problem of
portfolio optimization because
we are trying to figure out
which medicines to stock up on.
The one and
negative here it seems negative
or is that, it seems like this
problem has already received
a lot of attention.
And so as such it
wouldn't be up to us to,
we wouldn't be necessarily
the first ones to go into this,
we may have to coordinate
with lots of other groups.
But certainly a very important
problem and something that would
yield a longer term
interesting problem to work on.
Another one is educating
adolescents on sexual and
reproductive health, and this is
possibly a peer-based approach.
So we might take an approach
similar to the work
we've done using social
networks to educate people.
But the cultural context here
may be far more complex.
And so it wasn't clear if
from an AI perspective,
it would be as interesting.
But certainly a very
complicated problem.
Decision aids for health workers
based on decision trees.
So we want to have
this health workers ask
questions to diagnose diseases.
However, we can't ask
lots of questions, so
what's the right set
of questions to ask?
How to develop?
So, there's a POMDP
style framework that
could be developed to
generate these questions.
It seemed that this
could be a problem,
that's really important.
But maybe doesn't need a very
large scale collaboration.
But we are sort of keeping it in
terms of a problem that will be
in the future.
So go on, please.
>> I know that Brian Delancy
who used to be at [INAUDIBLE],
and now he's at Cape Town.
He has been working on such
a system for some time.
>> I see okay.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay.
>> For decision trees and
using that to [INAUDIBLE]
help workers.
>> Okay wonderful.
Okay so
that's my presentation on behalf
of the Public Health Group.
Does anybody else from the Group
want to add any comments or
anything?
Okay.